peu importe à quelle vitesse tu cours peu importe
jusqu'où tu vas la Bête suivra l'homme
ne peut pas échapper à son visage Hercule
ton nom
un cri de ralliement
nous connaissons tous ta légende tu es le fils
de Zeus Je veux seulement être un mari et
un père bienvenue
vous ne pouvez pas nier ce que vous êtes les dieux
vous puniront pour cela
les Gauss qui ont tué votre famille ont
déclenché l'enfer sur terre
les descendants d'Hadès ils ne peuvent pas être
tués par un mortel ordinaire les gens
ont besoin de vous je ne suis pas un héros avec un parcours
et je suis  plus fort qu'un dieu,
vengez-vous de votre famille, sauvez ces
gens,
gardez l'ordre dans ce monde,
mourons-nous dans cette bataille,
mon heure n'est pas encore venue, je ne suis pas encore sûr du vôtre, nous
combattrons la nourriture
et nous mourrons car vous
l'avez simulé vous-même,
dites-moi maintenant.  toi toi